est ce l'ancien ministre de l'ecologie
compare le parti écoutez bien à une
petite mafia avec ses parrains avec ses
fausses cartes quel tableau
quelles accusations c'est ça donc aussi
le ps je viendrai une mafia je crois que
ces mots ce sont les siens je vais la
droite défendre ces idées moi je ne j'ai
pris un principe dans cette période
je ne dis pas du mal des autres je
m'occupe de ce qui est le plus important
pour moi l'avenir du parti socialiste et
des propositions
le mot mafia ne vous laisse pas
indifférent le mot mafia me laisse pas
indifférent mais il ne laisse personne
indifférent mais j'ai beau alors je ne
vais pas commenter ces choses est ce que
c'est une insulte le mauvais fin jeudi
je ne vais pas faire l'événement
là-dessus dont je ne ferai pas de sitôt
elle dit ce qu'elle veut
sur le fond elle critique ont fait que
le seuil pour être candidat a été
relevée il faut désormais seize membres
du conseil national là où il en fallait
seulement un an auparavant
est-ce que effectivement il n'ya pas une
volonté du ps de verrouiller si vous
êtes comme elle le désire a fait cottage
traficotage pour reconduire les filles
il ya elle peut faire des ces objections
on en discutera et mais cette histoire
est pas nouvelle ça fait déjà deux mois
qu'on en parle donc il ya deux mois elle
aurait pu et au conseil national et il
ya je suis pas d'accord n'auraient pu en
discuter moi même j'avais des doutes là
dessus je les dis d'ailleurs en bureau
national
l'idée c'était non plus et c'était aussi
ne pas avoir une explosion de
candidature est dense et pouvant aller
bon voilà on en discutera calmement ya
pas besoin d'employer des mots aussi
forts